alors l'eau je me demandais écouté avec
beaucoup d'attention ce n'est pas très
long j pas descendu du genre j'applique
je suis par les jeux olympiques pour
présenter les coqs de combat assez
poignant the guardian pour tout le monde
première chose j'avais remercié avenue
dans mon ami président du conseil
régional de la guadeloupe a eu jamais je
connais très bien vient souvent nous ont
pas d'accord je n'ai pas peur je
l'assumé deuxièmement vous venez de
rappeler ce que j'étais
ce que je fus comme on vient de le dire
le moi est haïssable vous allez me fait
rigoler je ne peux pas je trait de plume
effacés je viens été fait comme si le
roman politique n'était pas une
continuité tout à fait normal on a été
intouchable honnête et ceux qui y jouent
size autres opéras mais mon collègue
boulonnais ce régime cherchait jason
interrogé pourquoi il était à voter toi
c'est tout simplement pas de chacun je
respecte la démocratie jeune élu du
peuple
je suis pas venu ici du chaque fois je
fais pour la ville de sainte-marie et tu
peux témoigner fois la quantité de
choses que je continue à faire envie à
terme à booster ce n'est pas le moment
de le faire le moment venu je l'annuaire
est copieusement afin qu'il n'y ait pas
d'ambiguïté hd niveau-là et son
engagement à ce niveau pour qu'il n'y
pas de problème ceci étant dit je suis
pas plus long pourquoi tout simplement
pas que j'appelle aujourd'hui dit si je
dois prendre l'avion et je dois aller
excusez-moi point de vtt m'éclate terme
et d'atteindre l'avion
wellwood amboise et 17 clubs c'est que
voilà donc je ne suis pas là ma taille
et partout où je serai je me le combat
que la responsabilité martin tétreault
clown je suis pas un amateur je suis pas
un opportuniste
je suis peu démago je suis jeune fille
je resterai toujours que je suis folle
au coin de pie xi et monsieur le préfet
je me retourne là vous je n'ai pas à
vous donner l'eau loge son public
ici tout ce qu'ils ont fait ça ont mal
agi et pas de leçon pour vous aussi à
vous donner à d'autres à lyon montchat
en gros on dit ce qu'on pense on
n'accuse pas l'état l'a publiquement
état n'est pas vain le jus ou de
discuter de nos problèmes intestinaux
on n'a pas ce droit là en fait pas de
moi un saint ce cas particulier c'est un
moment convivial
cela veut dit c'est un moment où en
arrivant au lancement de poubelles l'as
olemps et 5 le col à aulas est simple
kokkola les secours nationaux faire avec
on ne va la touchante et jamais je
n'avais jamais conduit et que j'aimerais
qu'il soit pour tout et qu'on l'a pasqua
comme ça on peut être fâché contre moi
je marque marie rose pour autant
est-ce que je ne suis pas d'accord à un
deuxième avis que par le service agit
j'ai toutes les villes de romandie et
puisqu'on n'a pas réagi on m'a donné
l'occasion de pouvoir voler les riches
tels que ce rachat ne l'est at elle
commis leurs plates de la magic est
complet à tout le capital mais son
actuel ou passé